Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is presented by Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. What does that mean? Well, say you need to make a presentation or a video or a social media post or a flyer to some, certainly to me, that sounds intimidating. But Tom, with Adobe Express's intuitive features like templates, generative AI and real-time collaboration,
感谢您收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、免广告收听、提前解锁系列内容并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问therestishistory.com并加入会员俱乐部。网址是therestishistory.com。本集由Adobe Express赞助播出，这是一款快捷简便、包罗万象的创作应用。这是什么意思呢？比如说，你需要制作一个演示文稿、视频、社交媒体帖子或传单，对某些人来说——特别是对本社长而言——听起来可能挺吓人的。但是，Tom，借助Adobe Express直观的功能，比如模板、生成式AI和实时协作，
it has never been easier. Adobe Express. Try it for free. Search Adobe Express in the App Store. during the Volvo Fall Experience event discover exceptional offers and thoughtful design that leaves plenty of room
这一切从未如此简单。Adobe Express。立即免费试用。在应用商店中搜索Adobe Express。在沃尔沃金秋体验季活动期间，探索非凡优惠与充满巧思的设计，为您留下充足的空间，
for autumn adventures and see for yourself how Volvo's legendary safety brings peace of mind to every crisp morning commute this September leased a 2026 XE90 plug-in hybrid
开启秋日探险。亲自体验沃尔沃传奇般的安全性能如何为这个九月的每一个清爽早晨通勤带来安心。本月起，租用2026款XC90插电式混合动力车，
from $599 biweekly at 3.99% during the Volvo Fall Experience event Conditions supply visit your local Volvo retailer or go to Explore Volvo So Tom, we have some incredibly exciting news for our listeners in Northern Ireland and the Republic of Ireland, don't we? We absolutely do, Dominic, because we are going to be in Belfast, in Dublin and in Cork next year in April.
双周租金低至599加元起，年利率3.99%，尽在沃尔沃金秋体验季活动。受条款约束，请访问当地沃尔沃经销商或访问Explore Volvo。所以，Tom，我们有一个对北爱尔兰和爱尔兰共和国的听众来说极其兴奋的消息，对吧？绝对是的，Dominic，因为我们明年四月要去贝尔法斯特、都柏林和科克。
And we will be talking about the tragic story of Titanic. We will be on stage in Belfast at the Waterfront Hall on Friday, 17th of April. We'll be in Dublin at the Convention Centre on Saturday the 18th of April and in Cork at the Opera House on Monday the 20th of April. Tickets will go on sale at the Restis History.com exclusively for members of the Restis History Club from next Monday the 22nd of September 2025 at 9 a.m. So join the Rest is History Club at the Restis History.com. now if you want to snap your tickets up early. And tickets will then be available to purchase for everyone else at therestishistory.com from next Thursday.
我们将探讨泰坦尼克号的悲惨故事。我们将于4月17日星期五在贝尔法斯特的水滨音乐厅（Waterfront Hall）登台演出；4月18日星期六在都柏林的会议中心（Convention Centre）演出；并于4月20日星期一体在科克的歌剧院（Opera House）演出。门票将于2025年9月22日星期一上午9点起，在therestishistory.com独家发售，仅限“历史俱乐部”（The Rest is History Club）会员购买。因此，如果你想早点抢到票，现在就去therestishistory.com加入历史俱乐部吧。门票随后将于下周四向所有人开放购买。
That's the 25th of September 2025 at 9am. So for your chance to see us on stage live in Belfast, Dublin or Cork, simply head to therestishistory.com to get your tickets. Rochester and Chatham are two distinct places, but contiguous, except the interval of a very small marsh or vacancy between Rochester and Chatham. There is little remarkable in Rochester, except the ruins of a very old castle and an ancient, but not extraordinary cathedral, but the river, and its appendices are the most consistent. considerable of the kind in the world. This being the chief arsenal of the Royal Navy of Great Britain. The buildings here are indeed like the ships themselves,
也就是2025年9月25日上午9点。因此，想要在贝尔法斯特、都柏林或科克现场观看我们演出的朋友，只需前往therestishistory.com即可购票。罗切斯特（Rochester）和查塔姆（Chatham）是两个不同的地方，但它们紧密相连，中间只有一小片沼泽或空地隔开。罗切斯特没有什么特别引人注目的地方，除了一个非常古老的城堡废墟和一个古老但并不算出奇的主教座堂，但这条河及其周边设施可以说是同类中世界上最雄伟的。
surprisingly large, and in their several kinds they're beautiful. The warehouses, or rather streets are warehouses and storehouses for laying up the naval treasure are the largest in dimension and the most in number that are anywhere to be seen in the world. the rope walk for making cables and the forges for anchors and other iron work bear up a portion to the rest as also the wet dock for keeping masts and yards are the greatest size where they lie sunk in the water to preserve them the boat yard the anchor yard all like the hole monstrously great and extensive they're not easily described so that tom was Daniel Defoe, who was a Londoner in the first volume of his tour through the whole island of Great Britain, published in 1724. It was a massive success, with the exception of
这里是大英帝国皇家海军的主要造船厂。这里的建筑确实和船只本身一样，大得惊人，而且在各自的类别中都非常精美。用于存放海军物资的仓库，或者更确切地说是街道般的仓库和货栈，其规模和数量是世界上任何地方都无可比拟的；用于制造缆绳的绳缆厂、用于制造锚和其他铁器的锻造厂，其规模都与其余部分相称；还有用于存放桅杆和帆桁的大型干船坞，它们浸没在水中以防腐蚀；造船厂、锚具厂，所有这些都大得离谱、无边无际，难以一一描述。所以，Tom，这是丹尼尔·笛福（Daniel Defoe），他是一位伦敦人，在他的《全英岛屿巡礼》第一卷中写道，该书出版于1724年。
Robinson Crusoe. It was by far his best-selling book, but never before has it been read out on the top of Rochester Castle on a grey and slightly dreary day in howling wind to an audience of bored-looking camera people. So very exciting scenes. Yeah, because this is the long-awaited episode on Chatham High Street, but not just Chatham High Street, intra-chatam, which is the stretch
除了《鲁滨逊漂流记》，这是他迄今最畅销的书籍，但在此之前，还从来没有人顶着狂风、在阴沉且略显沉闷的灰色日子里，于罗切斯特城堡的顶端向一群面无表情的摄像师朗读过这段文字。真是一个非常刺激的场景。没错，因为这是备受期待的查塔姆高街（Chatham High Street）特辑，不仅是查塔姆高街，还有“内查塔姆”（Intra-Chatham），也就是那段
that leads us on to Rochester High Street, and we are on the 100-foot summit of the keep of Rochester Castle. So Daniel Defoe, just for people who don't know, Defoe was, he wasn't just Britain's first novelist. He was Britain's, one of Britain's greatest journalists, wasn't he? And he did this tour of the whole island of Great Britain, and he published it just a couple of decades after the Act of Union had created a United Kingdom out of England and Scotland. So this is a moment in British history like no other.
通往罗切斯特高街的延伸段，而我们正站在罗切斯特城堡主楼100英尺高的峰顶上。那么丹尼尔·笛福——对于不太了解的人来说——笛福不仅是英国的第一位小说家，他还是英国最伟大的记者之一，对吧？他进行了这次全英岛屿的巡礼，并在《联合法案》将英格兰和苏格兰合并为联合王国之后的短短几十年内将其出版。所以这是英国历史上无与伦比的一个时刻。
It's a point in which Britain is poised on the brink of absolutely enormous political, economic, diplomatic change. Absolutely. And Defoe essentially loved change. He loved the idea of progress. progress, very whiggish, isn't it? And although DeFoe ended up working essentially as a kind of spy for a Tory government, I think in his instincts, he was all about the wigs. So as a young man, he had fought for the Duke of Monmouth against his uncle, the Catholic King James II, and Monmouth's rebellion had gone disastrously badly. But DeFoe had managed to avoid being hanged, which is good news for fans of Robertson-Cruzzo
这是英国正处于一场绝对巨大的政治、经济、外交变革边缘的关键节点。确实如此。而笛福本质上非常热爱变革。他喜欢进步的概念，非常具有辉格党（Whig）色彩，不是吗？尽管笛福最终实质上是作为保守党（Tory）政府的某种间谍在工作，但我认为从他的直觉来看，他骨子里完全是个辉格党人。因此，作为一个年轻人，他曾为蒙茅斯公爵（Duke of Monmouth）而战，对抗他的叔叔、天主教国王詹姆斯二世（King James II），而蒙茅斯的叛乱结果灾难般地惨败。但笛福设法避免了被绞死的命运，这对《鲁滨逊漂流记》的粉丝来说是个好消息，
and 18th century travelogues around Britain. He'd loved the glorious revolution when James II got kicked out and replaced by the Protestant William and Mary and he'd been a big enthusiast for the acts of union between England and Scotland and had actively worked to promote them actually. And as you can probably tell from that accent,
对18世纪的英国游记爱好者来说也是如此。他热爱“光荣革命”，当时詹姆斯二世被赶下台，由信奉新教的威廉和玛丽取而代之；他还是英格兰和苏格兰《联合法案》的坚定支持者，并积极为之进行过推广。正如你从那种口音中大概能听出来的那样，
which is exactly how he spoke, his origins were in trade. He's a mercantile man, isn't he? So he'd worked as a wine merchant. So that perhaps explains one, that's one reason why he's so keen on the Royal Navy, the idea of commerce, of Britannia ruling the waves, and of course he loves a naval dockyard. He absolutely does. And just to say as well, that, you know, he had sailed the seeds.
这正是他说话的方式，他的出身与商业有关。他是个商人，对吧？所以他曾当过葡萄酒商人。这或许解释了一点，这也是他为什么如此热衷于皇家海军、商业理念、不列颠统治海洋，当然还有他极其喜爱海军造船厂的原因。他确实如此。顺便也要提一下，你知道的，他曾乘船远航过。
He'd been a wine merchant. Dominant, you love a Portuguese wine depot in the 18th century, don't you? And Defoe was kind of always hanging out there. And so it's not surprising, really, that when he comes to Rochester, which he describes as having a castle and cathedral. He looks as it as being rather boring and old. And Chatham, which is where the royal dockyards are, he is all over that. He thinks it's incredible.
他曾是一名葡萄酒商人。Dominic，你不是很喜欢18世纪的葡萄牙葡萄酒仓库吗？而笛福过去总是流连在那里。因此，当他来到罗切斯特——他将其描述为拥有城堡和大教堂的地方时，并不感到意外，因为他觉得那里相当无趣和古老。而查塔姆——也就是皇家造船厂所在地，他对此可以说是全情投入，觉得这简直不可思议。
He thinks it's absolutely wonderful. And I think that that's why that passage describing Rochester and Chatham is absolutely brilliant for pinpointing this idea of Britain as being on the kind of cusp of incredible change. Yeah. So there's a world of kind of warehouses and dockyards and battleships. global trade and free trade and all that kind of stuff and this is the sort of this is the central access this is the hub of that of that world isn't it rochester and chatham these kind of twin towns across the medway so tom give us a little bit of a tour d'orison so the reason that
他觉得这简直妙不可言。我认为，正是这段描写罗切斯特和查塔姆的文字，对于精准捕捉英国正处于不可思议变革边缘这一理念具有绝对绝妙的意义。没错。所以这里是一个充满仓库、造船厂和战列舰的世界，充满了全球贸易、自由贸易等等诸如此类的东西，而这就是某种意义上的中心轴线，是那个世界的枢纽，不是吗？罗切斯特和查塔姆，这两个横跨麦德威河（Medway）的孪生城镇。所以，Tom，给我们做一个简短的概述吧。我们来这里的
we're here is obviously because i've bullied you into doing it you've put up a heroic three year rearguard action but at last we're here in rochester in chatton you know what ladies and gentlemen when I look at Tom's notes and now that I'm here on site I could not be more excited I'm absolutely gog with excitement because there are so many delights to come in this episode
原因显然是因为我强迫你来的。你进行了长达三年英勇的后卫战，但最后我们还是来到了罗切斯特和查塔姆。你知道吗，女士们先生们，当我看着Tom的笔记，以及现在身临其境时，我简直兴奋得无以复加。我激动得心花怒放，因为这一集中将有太多的精彩内容等待着大家，
there's Dickens, there's naval stuff there might be a mentioner for a show Nelson there's people wrestling on the floor of a chapel or something it is probably the most exciting the most action-packed the most blood-soaked and in many ways the most moving episode
这里有狄更斯（Dickens），有海军元素，可能还会提到纳尔逊（Nelson），有人在小教堂的地板上摔跤之类的。这可能是有史以来我们在《历史的其余部分》中做过的最激动人心、最扣人心弦、最血腥，且在许多方面最令人感动的节目。
that we've ever done on the rest is history the reason that I wanted to do it is that I've been walking the Saxon Shore way, which is a kind of national route that follows the coastline of Kent, which for those people not familiar with the geography of England is the bit in the southeast that sticks out into the sea. And I realized coming here that Rochester High Street becomes Chatham High Street. And I felt that the way in which you go from kind of, well, we've got an Iron Age hill fort, we've got a Roman bridge, we've got an Anglo-Saxon Cathedral, we've got a Norman castle,
我之所以想做这一集，是因为我一直在走“萨克森海岸步道”（Saxon Shore Way），这是一条沿着肯特郡海岸线延伸的国家步道。对于不熟悉英格兰地理的人来说，肯特郡就是东南部凸入大海的那一部分。我来到这里时意识到，罗切斯特高街直接连成了查塔姆高街。我觉得从这里的发展历程来看，我们拥有铁器时代的山地堡垒、罗马时代的桥梁、盎格鲁-撒克逊的主教座堂、诺曼时代的城堡，
and yet you end up with Chatham Docks, this kind of great nerve centre of British imperial expansion. I am making the pitch that this is the most historic street in England. Surely the world, Tom. No? Well, I think in Britain you can make a case for the Royal Marley in Edinburgh, which has Rhearood and Edinburgh Castle and the grave of Adam Smith and all kinds of things like that. But this work, if you want a sense of the sweep and sweep,
然而最终呈现的却是查塔姆船坞——英国帝国扩张的伟大神经中枢。我在此断言，这是英格兰最具历史意义的一条街道。难道不是全世界吗，Tom？不是吗？嗯，我认为在英国，你可以为爱丁堡的皇家一英里（Royal Mile）争辩一番，那里有荷里路德宫（Palace of Holyroodhouse）、爱丁堡城堡、亚当·斯密（Adam Smith）的墓等等诸如此类的东西。但是这项工作，如果你想感受那种历史的巨浪与全景，
ban and process of change that manifests itself through English history, Rochester High Street, Chatham High Street, if you think of it as a single road, I mean, is absolutely fantastic. And you, as Defoe says, Rochester is all about the kind of traditional England of tourist brochures. Yeah. Chatham is about energy and industry and transformation. And you could say, I think, that in the 18th and 19th centuries, it's a kind of cross between the Pentagon and Silicon Valley.
以及在英格兰历史中展现出的变革进程，罗切斯特高街、查塔姆高街——如果你把它们看作是一条单一的道路——我的意思是，绝对是极其精彩的。正如笛福所说，罗切斯特关乎旅游手册里那种传统的英格兰。而查塔姆则关乎活力、工业和转型。你可以说，在18世纪和19世纪，它有点像是五角大楼和硅谷的结合体。
And Chatham right now, I mean, it's retained that reputation, hasn't it, Tom, as a glittering cosmopolitan on the front line of technological and social change, no? I fear not. So the Chatham dockyards shut in 1984. And I think it would be fair to say that if you're an enthusiast for vape shops or possibly to two parlors, Chatham High Street now is very much the place to go. I actually love both of those things. So it's great. it's probably not at the cutting edge of naval technology now in the way that it used to be. So I think it's fair to say that Chatham has seen happier days. And in that again, of course, it's an exemplar of British history because obviously Britain is not the great power that it was in the 18th and 19th centuries. And so if Chatham exemplifies the rise to global greatness of Britain, there's also a sense in which its current state tells you about Britain's relative decline. But before we do some history, why don't we have a little excursion into geography?
而现在的查塔姆，我的意思是，它保留了那种名声，不是吗，Tom？作为一个处于技术和社会变革最前沿的光鲜亮丽的国际化大都市，对吧？我恐怕不是。所以查塔姆造船厂在1984年关闭了。我想可以说，如果你是电子烟店或纹身店的爱好者，现在的查塔姆绝对是个好去处。其实我两样都很喜欢。所以这挺棒的。它现在可能不像过去那样处于海军技术的最前沿了。所以我觉得可以说，查塔姆已经大不如前了。从这一点上来说，它再次成为了英国历史的一个缩影，因为显而易见，英国已经不再是18世纪和19世纪那个伟大的强国了。因此，如果查塔姆诠释了英国走向全球伟大地位的崛起，那么在某种意义上，它现状也反映了英国相对衰落的历史。但在我们开始讲历史之前，为什么我们不进行一次地理的小远足呢？
We don't do enough geography on the rest of history. And Theo in particular is a passionate aficionado of geography. So Tom, talk to Theo and indeed the listeners about geography. Yeah, well, geography, of course, so important to the study of history because so often geography is historical destiny. And that is definitely the case with Rochester and Chatham. So just to set the geographical scene for people. who may not be O'Fay with North Kent.
我们在《历史的其余部分》中涉及的地理内容还不够多。特别是Theo，他是一个充满热情的地理爱好者。所以，Tom，跟Theo以及我们的听众们聊聊地理吧。好的，地理，当然，对于历史研究来说至关重要，因为地理往往就是历史的宿命。对于罗切斯特和查塔姆来说绝对也是如此。所以，为了给那些可能对北肯特郡不太熟悉的听众们勾勒出地理场景：
So we are just south of the Thames Estuary, the stretch of water that extends from London outwards into the North Sea. So we've got Essex to the north, and we in Kent on the south coast of the Thames Estuary. And we are standing beside the Medway, which is a river that rises in Kent and flows northwards out into the Thames Estuary. And Rochester and Chatham both stand on the Medway and would not have come into existence without the Medway. So to talk about Rochester first, why is Rochester where it is?
我们位于泰晤士河口（Thames Estuary）以南，也就是从伦敦向外延伸到北海的那片水域。所以北面是埃塞克斯郡（Essex），而我们在泰晤士河口南岸的肯特郡。我们站在麦德威河畔，这是一条发源于肯特郡并向北流入泰晤士河口的河流。罗切斯特和查塔姆都坐落在麦德威河畔，如果没有麦德威河，它们就不会存在。那么先来谈谈罗切斯特，为什么罗切斯特会在这个地方？
Basically, because it is the lowest bridging point on the river Medway. So essentially, if you want to get across the Medway, Rochester is the place to come. And in that, its relationship to the Medway is equivalent to London's relationship to the Thames. And as with London, it's the Romans who build London Bridge. So here it's the Romans who build the first bridge over the Medway. But even before the Romans come, there is a trackway here that leads from Dover, the southeastern tip of Kent, up towards the River Thames. And this is the fording point.
基本上是因为它是麦德威河上下游最低的架桥点。所以本质上，如果你想过麦德威河，罗切斯特就是你要来的地方。在这方面，它与麦德威河的关系就相当于伦敦与泰晤士河的关系。正如伦敦的情况一样，是罗马人建造了伦敦桥。所以在这里，是罗马人建造了麦德威河上的第一座桥。但甚至在罗马人到来之前，这里就有一条小路，从肯特郡东南角的多佛（Dover）一直延伸到泰晤士河。这就是渡河点。
So kind of very much kind of Iron Age highway. And this is the highway that in due course will come to be called Watling Street, one of the great roads of England. And so where is that, Tom? Is that right here? Yeah. So that bridge that you can see there, if you're watching this on YouTube, and essentially Chatham High Street, Rochester High Street,
所以这在很大程度上可以说是铁器时代的交通要道。这就是后来被称为沃特林街（Watling Street）的道路，它是英格兰伟大的道路之一。那么那条路在哪里，Tom？就在这里吗？是的。所以你看到的那个桥，如果你正在YouTube上观看这个节目，基本上查塔姆高街、罗切斯特高街，
that's all part of Watling Street. So essentially, when the Romans under Julius Caesar land here in 55 and then 54 BC, in 54 BC Caesar advances towards the Thames, he would almost certainly have come this way. And again, we can be pretty confident that in AD 43, when Claudius sends three legions here under Alis Plautius, again, they would have come here. And in fact, we know that there is a great two-day battle on the Medway,
这些都是沃特林街的一部分。所以本质上，当罗马人在公元前55年和公元前54年由尤利乌斯·恺撒（Julius Caesar）率领在此登陆时，在公元前54年恺撒向泰晤士河推进时，他几乎肯定走的是这条路。同样，我们可以相当确定，在公元43年，当克劳迪娅斯（Claudius）派遣奥卢斯·普劳蒂乌斯（Aulus Plautius）率领三个军团来到这里时，他们也会走这里。事实上，我们知道在麦德威河上曾发生过一场为期两天的宏大战役，
perhaps here more likely a little bit further south. And Vespasian, who will go on to become the emperor, he crosses the river with his Batavian cavalry, who have this extraordinary ability to swim in full armour. So very exciting scenes. It's unbelievably exciting. And I cannot describe it. It's such a shame that the listeners,
也许就在这里，但更有可能在稍南一点的地方。韦斯帕芗（Vespasian）——日后将成为罗马皇帝——他率领他的巴达维亚骑兵渡过了这条河，这些骑兵拥有穿着全套盔甲游泳的非凡能力。所以场面非常刺激。这令人难以置信地激动人心。我无法形容。真遗憾，听众们，
and even the people watching on YouTube, can't actually be here because the air is electric with excitement, isn't it? To be here in this spot where it actually happened. Unbelievable history. Well, can I just crank up the excitement by revealing the name that the Romans give to the town that they built here? It's Durobrivi, which means almost certainly stronghold by the bridge. I mean, couldn't be more exciting.
甚至是通过YouTube观看的人，都无法身临其境，因为这里的空气中弥漫着令人兴奋的电流，不是吗？能够在这个真正发生过历史的地方。令人难以置信的历史。好吧，我能不能通过透露罗马人给他们在这里建立的城镇起的名字来进一步提升这种兴奋感？它叫Durobrivi，几乎可以肯定意思是“桥边的堡垒”。我的天，没有比这更刺激的了。
And both Watling Street and this bridge built by the Romans survive the Roman occupation, don't they? basically because they're just so well located. So if you're going to Dover, if you are coming from Dover, if you're going to London, you're going to go this way. Yes. So it's absolutely the kind of, it's essentially, it's the great road that links London and everything that lies beyond London to Dover and therefore to the continent. But enough of Rochester.
无论是沃特林街还是这座由罗马人建造的桥，都在罗马占领结束后幸存了下来，对吧？基本上是因为它们的地理位置实在是太好了。所以如果你要去多佛，如果你是从多佛来，如果你要去伦敦，你都会走这条路。是的。所以它绝对可以说是，本质上，它是连接伦敦以及伦敦以外的一切事物与多佛、进而连接到欧洲大陆的康庄大道。不过，罗切斯特就聊到这里吧。
There's been a lot of Rochester so far. Where's Chatham? Talk to me about Chatham. Well, the view of Chatham is on the other side of the keep where we're standing now. I'm looking at it now. It's gorgeous. It's absolutely stunning. I think Dominic, we should get Harry to move the cameras and go over on the other side of the keep.
到目前为止，我们已经讲了很多关于罗切斯特的内容。查塔姆在哪里？跟我讲讲查塔姆。嗯，查塔姆的景色就在我们现在站立的城堡主楼的另一边。我现在正看着它。太美了。简直绝美。我想多米尼克，我们应该让哈里把摄像机移开，去城堡主楼的另一边。
Two. So as you can see if you are watching on Spotify or on YouTube, we have now moved to the other side of the castle. And the sense of drama, tension and jeopardy is becoming more acute with every moment for two reasons. Number one, the wind has now reached gale force levels. And secondly, the staff of the castle are having to fight. off a huge throng downstairs. Two different groups. One, a group of Restis History
二。所以正如大家所见，如果你正在Spotify或YouTube上观看，我们现在已经移到了城堡的另一边。随着每一刻的推移，这种戏剧性、紧张感和危机感变得愈发强烈，原因有二。第一，风现在已经达到了烈风的程度。第二，城堡的工作人员不得不奋力抵挡楼下庞大的人群。两群不同的人。第一群，是一群“历史的残余”俱乐部成员，他们刚刚在restishistory.com上注册。我听说汤姆·霍兰也在。他们非常兴奋。另一群是一群小学生，汤姆禁止他们来到城堡顶部，这毁了他们的郊游日，甚至很可能毁了他们对历史的热爱，直到永远。
club members who've just signed up at the Restis History.com. And I've heard that Tom Holland is here. They're very excited. And the other, a group of school children whom Tom has forbidden from coming to the top of the castle, ruining their outing their day
并且极有可能永远毁了他们对历史的热爱。但汤姆，告诉我们，告诉所有在Spotify和YouTube上观看的观众，为什么你禁止这些孩子来到城堡顶端，这样你就可以谈论查塔姆了。好吧，我会在那群心碎的12岁历史迷们的啜泣声中尽量试一试。但对我们来说，站在这个100英尺高的诺曼城堡主楼的顶峰是非常重要的，
and quite possibly their love of history forever. But Tom, tell us, tell everybody watching on Spotify and YouTube why you have barred these children from coming to the top of the castle so that you can talk about Chatham. Well, I'll try to do it over the sound of the sobbing of distraught 12-year-old history fans. But it's important for us to be on the summit of this 100-foot Norman keep
因为我们来到了另一边，现在你可以看到美德way河的蜿蜒。我们讨论过美德way河如何是罗切斯特的关键。它也是查塔姆的关键。所以查塔姆比罗切斯特更靠近大海，这意味着如果你驾驶一艘庞大的都铎王朝船只，这就变得更加便利了，16世纪开始出现这种情况，因为英国正在扩大其全球利益、贸易、海盗活动，最终是征战。伊丽莎白女王的宫廷开始意识到它地理位置极佳，介于伦敦和通往世界的航运路线之间。
because we've come to the other side and now you can see the sweep of the medway. And we talked about how the medway is key to Rochester. It's also the key to Chatham. So Chatham is closer to the sea than Rochester, which means that. that it is much more convenient should you be sailing an enormous Tudor ship, which is what starts to happen in the 16th century, because England is expanding its global interests, trade, piracy, ultimately conquest. And the Elizabethan court starts to realize that it's ideally situated between London
所以，在1568年，伊丽莎白一世正式将查塔姆设为皇家造船厂。从那时起，它在皇家海军的发展以及英国（随后是英国）与更广阔世界的接触中发挥了基础性作用，这当然最终导致了大英帝国建立。显然，这是一个历经几个世纪的过程，查塔姆在18世纪和19世纪演变成地球上最具未来感的地方，是一个庞大的、长期的、由政府资助的计划，
and the kind of the shipping lanes that lead to the... world. So in 1568, Elizabeth I first formally institutes Chatham as a royal dockyard. And from that point on, it plays a fundamental role in the growth of the Royal Navy and the emergence of first English and then British engagement with the broader world, which of course ultimately will result in the establishment of the British Empire. And obviously, that is a process that takes centuries. and the emergence of Chatham as what it becomes in the 18th and into the 19th century to the most futuristic place on the face of the planet is a huge, huge, long-term government-sponsored plan
也许你可以说英国国家有点忘记了如何去参与的那种计划。但与其说是成功，不如说它同样诞生于失败，对不对？因为我们现在所在的地方——美德way河，是世界历史上最不光彩、最背信弃义、最终也是微不足道的时刻之一的发生地，不是吗？也就是荷兰突袭美德way河。他们是坏人，而且他们真的很让人失望。所以那是在1667年6月，它是英格兰和荷兰共和国之间正在进行的一系列战争的一部分。
of the kind perhaps you might say that the British state has slightly forgotten how to engage in. But born as much of failure as success, right? Because where we are now, the Medway, is the location for one of the most disgraceful, perfidious, ultimately insignificant moments in world history, isn't it? Which is the Dutch raid on the Medway. They're bad people and they really let themselves down. So that's in June 1667 and it's part of a series of wars that England and the Dutch Republic are waging against each other.
这是查理二世统治下的第二轮战争，他刚从在荷兰的流亡中归来，我们随后会听到更多关于这方面的内容。在17世纪60年代，荷兰人和查理二世相处得一点也不好。正如我们所说，在1667年，荷兰人逆美德way河而上，他们发现用来保护造船厂以及所有停泊在那里的船只的防御设施根本不合格。他们烧毁或俘获了13艘英国船只，多米尼克，在一场令人震惊的盗窃表演中，他们拖走了“皇家查理号”（HMS Royal Charles），这是英国海军的旗舰，耻辱的是，它至今仍在荷兰国家博物馆（Rijksmuseum）展出。
This is the second bout of war under the reign of Charles II who's just come back after his exile in the Netherlands and we'll be hearing more about that in due course. And the Dutch and Charles II aren't getting on well at all in the 1660. And as we say, in 1667, the Dutch sail up the medway and they find that the defences in place to protect the dockyards and all the ships that are at anchor there just aren't up to scratch. And they burn or capture 13 English ships and Dominic in a shocking display of thieving. They haul away HMS Royal Charles, which is the flagship of the English Navy. and disgracefully, it's still on display
你想知道丹尼尔·笛福是怎么说的吗？是的。告诉我他是怎么说的。我知道你挺喜欢丹尼尔·笛福的。他对这件事有着辛辣的看法。他说：“这次惊扰给英国带来了对美德way河、查塔姆的所有船坞和造船厂的重要性的如此深刻的认识，
in the Rikes Museum to this day. Do you want to know what Daniel Defoe? Yeah. Tell me what he said. I know you like a bit, Daniel DeFoe. He had pungent views about this. He said, This alarm gave England such a sense of the consequence
这次惊扰——他改变了声音，因为他游历了全国。是的，他模仿了不同的口音。他说，这次惊扰给英国带来了对美德way河、查塔姆的所有船坞和造船厂以及英国海军暴露在那里的危险的如此深刻的认识，
of the River Madway and of all the docks and yards of Chathamick. This alarm, he changed the voice because he toured the country. Yeah, it picked up. It picked up different accents. He said, this alarm, guy of England, such a sense of the consequence of the River Medway, and of all the docks and yards at Chatham, and of the danger of the Royal Navy I exposed to there,
以至于所有当时敞开的大门从那时起都被锁上并充分加固了，现在天下没有任何一个国家——一个国家，我不知道那里发生了什么——尽管它们可能称霸海上，除非它们同时也在陆地上称霸，否则不可能再给我们这样一次羞辱。我其实不知道最后那句话是什么意思，
that all these doors which are open then are locked up and sufficiently barred since that time, and tis not now in the power of any nation under heaven, a nation, I don't know what happened there, though they should be masters at sea, unless they were masters at land too at the same time to give us such another affront. I don't actually know what that last bit means
因为我刚才被那种口音分心了。他是什么意思？他的意思是，对美德way河的突袭对英国国家是一个如此巨大的震惊，以至于从红way河一直延伸到查塔姆的沿线，特别是在进入美德way河的河口，都建立了绝对坚不可摧的防御工事。基本上他是说，即使海上霸权不再属于英国，人们仍然无法强行闯入，唯一可能摧毁查塔姆的方式就是发生陆地入侵。笛福是对的，因为查塔姆在七年战争、拿破仑战争期间都坚不可摧，我们在关于纳尔逊的剧集里讨论过，拿破仑对英国的计划——如果他能把军队运送过海的话——就是直接进军查塔姆并将其摧毁。我的意思是，这相当于摧毁了今天的某种核防御系统之类的东西。
because I was just so distracted by the accent. What does he mean? What he means is that the raid on the Medway was such a shock to the British state that absolutely impregnable defences were put in place all the way along the line of the redway up to Chatham and particularly at the mouth of the estuary going into the medway and essentially he's saying that even if naval supremacy
它历经第一次世界大战而幸存，历经第二次世界大战而幸存。在所有这些冲突中，以及在19世纪漫长的和平岁月中，查塔姆既是英国作为伟大全球大国的角色的象征，也是其支点。所以在此之前，汤姆，简单说一下，因为小学生们正挤着爬上楼梯。英国本身当然曾是一个伟大帝国的一部分，它是罗马帝国帝国网络中的一个节点。事实上，我们一直在俯瞰沃特林街（Watling Street）和大桥，对吧？再多讲一点那座桥，因为你很喜欢那桥。
were to pass from Britain, people still wouldn't be able to force their way in and the only conceivable way in which Chatham could be destroyed would be if there was a land invasion. And Defoe is right because Chatham stands impregnable throughout the Seven Years' War, throughout the Napoleonic Wars, and we talked in our episodes on Nelson about how Napoleon's plan for England, if he only get his troops across, was to march straight on Chatham and destroy it. I mean, it would be the equivalent of knocking out, I don't know,
是的，正如你所说，美德way河上的第一座桥，可能是罗马人之前就有的桥，然后罗马人通过巨大的石墩和横跨其上的木板对其进行了开发。这座桥在罗马权力崩溃后很久依然存在。它可能一直存在到8世纪或9世纪，当时又被重建。之所以如此重要，正如我们所说，这是从多佛（多佛是大陆最短的过海点）到伦敦最快的路线。因此，在罗马人撤离之后，罗马再次与已经成为盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰的地方建立联系，并非通过军事手段，而是通过精神手段，当时在6世纪末，圣奥古斯丁带着一帮修士抵达，试图将信奉异教的盎格鲁-撒克逊人改宗。
a kind of nuclear defence system or something like that today. And it survives the First World War, it survives the Second World War. And throughout those conflicts and also throughout the long decades of peace in the 19th century, Chatham, I guess, is both the symbol and the fulcrum of Britain's role as a great global power. So before that, Tom, just quickly, because the school children are fighting their way up the stairs. Britain was, of course, herself part of a great empire, and it was a kind of node in the imperial network of the Roman Empire. And actually, we've been looking down at Watling Street and the Great Bridge, haven't we? Just say a little bit more about that bridge, because you love that bridge.
他的最初计划是到达伦敦并在那里建立一个大主教区，但他们没有去，因为伦敦可以说是充满敌意的领土。因此众所周知，他们在坎特伯雷停了下来，这就是为什么英国教会的领袖至今仍在坎特伯雷的原因。这也是盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰建造第一座大教堂的地方。但是第二座盎格鲁-撒克逊大教堂建于604年，就在我们站立的这个地方附近。它由一个叫尤斯图斯（Justus）的人在罗切斯特建立，他像奥古斯丁一样来自罗马。它极其古老。我的意思是，笛福说它不是很引人注目，但我的意思是，从某种意义上说它很有趣，你知道的，
Yeah, so, as you've said, the first bridge over the Medway, probably upon mountain bridge and then the Romans develop it with great stone piers and kind of wooden planks across it. And that bridge endures well after the collapse of Roman power. And it's there probably up until 8th or 9th centuries when it gets rebuilt again. And the reason that's so important, as we said, it's the quickest way to get from Dover, which is the shortest crossing point from the continent, up to London. And so it's not surprising that in the wake of the Roman withdrawal. Rome makes contact again with what's become Anglo-Saxon England, not with military means, but with spiritual means when at the end of the sixth century, St. Augustine arrives
这把我们一直带回了罗马教会对英格兰的最早日子，回到了格里高利大帝的时代。而且我，你知道，我觉得这非常感人。这有一种活生生的联系感。是的，你很喜欢这个，对吧？我是。它被征服者威廉赐予了奥多，一个买主，对吧？是的，所以盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰随着诺曼征服而结束，在我们关于那段历史的剧集中，我们讨论过威廉如何从黑斯廷斯出发去多佛并攻占它，然后去伦敦。他经由罗切斯特而来。所以他看到这是一个绝对至关重要的必争之地。因此他同母异父的弟弟奥多——他是一位主教，但非常喜欢打仗。众所周知，作为一名主教，你不被允许流血。所以他用大棒或权标杀死人们，
with a band of monks to convert the pagan Anglo-Saxons. And his original plan is to get to London and establish an archbishopric there, but they don't because London is kind of hostile territory. So famously, they stop in Canterbury, and that's why the head of the Church of England is in Canterbury to this day. And that is where the first cathedral in Anglo-Saxon England is built. But the second Anglo-Saxon cathedral, which is founded in 604, is down there from where we are standing. And it's founded in Rochester by a guy called Justice, who, like Augustine, is from Rome. And it's incredibly old. I mean, Defoe says it's. It's. It says it's not very interesting, but it's, I mean, it is interesting in the sense that, you know,
而威廉将罗切斯特的主教管区赐予了奥多。但奥多是个非常坏的人。他非常背信弃义。他被赶走了。于是威廉将它赐给了一个名叫——不是甘道夫，是贡道夫（Gundulf），但非常相似的非凡之人。他在威廉的生涯中扮演着有点甘道夫式的角色。
this takes us right the way back to the earliest days of the Roman church in England, back to the age of Gregory the Great. And I, you know, I find it very moving. It's kind of a sense of a living link. Yeah, you love that, don't you? I do. It was given to Odo, a buyer, by William the Conqueror, no? Yeah, so Anglo-Saxon England comes to an end with the Norman conquest, and in our episode on that. We talked about how William from Hastings goes to Dover and captures it and then goes to London. And he comes via Rochester. So he sees that it's an absolutely kind of crucial place to seize. And so his half-brother, Odo, who is a bishop, but very fond of fighting. So famously, you know, as a bishop, you're not allowed to shed blood. So he kills people with a club or a
因为他是一个取得了非凡成就的人。他非常非常聪明，非常擅长创造事物。所以他是一位伟大的建筑师。他是一位伟大的工程师。正是贡道夫在伦敦建造了白塔，这成为了伦敦塔的基础。1083年，他在这里的罗切斯特开始着手重建那座基本上已经支离破碎的盎格鲁-撒克逊大教堂。它非常破旧。他实际建造的建筑现在没剩下多少了，除了一个叫做贡道夫塔的地方，真烦人，我们从这里实际上看不到它。无论如何，我的意思是，人们如果对贡道夫感兴趣，仍然可以看到他的塔。所以，这真是极好的播客节目。确实如此。它在中世纪经历了几次改造。在13世纪，它度过了一段特别倒霉的时期，当时英格兰最糟糕的国王约翰洗劫了它，然后
mace. And William gives Rochester as a bishopric to Odo. But Odo is. He's a very bad man. He is very treacherous. And he gets chucked out. And so William gives it to this remarkable man who is called, it's not Gandalf, it's Gundalf, but quite similar. And he has a slightly, you know, it's Gandalfesque role in William's career.
自封为英格兰议会之父的西蒙·德·蒙福特（Simon De Montfort）也洗劫了它。而且我认为总给人一种它有点破旧的感觉。佩普斯（Pepys）在16世纪就是这样描述它的。我们听到笛福说它古老但不寻常。
Because he's a man who achieves extraordinary things. He's very, very smart, very proficient at creating things. So he's a great architecture. architect. He's a great engineer. And it's Gundulf who builds the white tower in London, which becomes the kind of the basis for the Tower of London. And in 1083, he starts work here in Rochester on renewing the Anglo-Saxon cathedral that had basically kind of fallen to pieces. It was very decrepit. Not much of what he actually built survives, except for a place called Gundolf's Tower, which annoyingly we can't actually see from here. Anyway, I mean, people are interested in
再说一次，我的意思是，我认为这挺公道的。但挑出一些亮点。所以这里有一个不错的地下室。有一个地下室。那是贡道夫建造的。所以甘道夫的粉丝们不仅可以看到他的塔，还可以看到那个。你对西立面很兴奋，对吧？非常兴奋。
Goldelf, you can still see his tower. So, this is great podcasting. It really is. And it gets remodeled throughout the middle ages. It has a particularly bad time in the 13th century when King John, England's worst king, lutes it. And then
上面有基督、正义女神和其他人。国王埃塞尔伯特（Ethelbert），他曾欢迎奥古斯丁和他的传教士来到肯特。还有一个漂亮的带有绿人的天花板。你很喜欢绿人。但最重要的是，你告诉我的那件事，我其实觉得相当感人，你说最能让你比以往任何时候都更接近超自然维度的一件事是，在2019年，你在大教堂中心打了迷你高尔夫。2019年，步圣尤斯图斯和贡道夫主教的后尘，大教堂当局在大教堂的中殿设立了一个迷你高尔夫球场。我能告诉大家你当时——所以在汤姆在大教堂打完高尔夫后，他给我发了一条短信，
Simon DeMontford, the self-style father of the English parliament, he lutes it as well. And I think there's always a sense that it's a little bit shabby. That's how Peep's described it in the 16th century. We heard DeFoe, saying it was ancient but not extraordinary.
他说：“多米尼克，在玩冒险高尔夫时，我真的感觉到，我反思了在我们自己的生活以及当今世界中需要建造的桥梁。”多米尼克，你知道我当时的那个反思有什么神奇之处吗？是的。几天后，罗切斯特教区发布了一条消息，称我们希望在玩冒险高尔夫时，游客能够反思在我们自己的生活以及当今世界中需要建造的桥梁。所以这太不可思议了。
And again, I mean, I think that's kind of fair. But pick out some highlights. So there's a nice crypt. There's a crypt. So that was built by Gundolf. So Gandalf fans can see that as well as his tower. You're excited about the Great Westall, aren't you? Very excited.
罗切斯特教区又一次黑了我们的短信。简直难以置信。带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，在我们下山并让小学生们上来之前，让我们非常快速地继续谈谈罗切斯特城堡。跟我讲讲罗切斯特城堡的历史。所以这最初是什么，诺曼式的？是的，所以你在前面读到的笛福的那段话，我的意思是，他对大教堂非常粗鲁，也许并非不公平，但他曾说城堡只是一片废墟，我的意思是，我们正站在
It's got Christ and it's got justice and someone else. King Ethelbert, who welcomed Augustine and his missionaries to Ken. And there's another lovely ceiling with some green men. You love a green man. But most of all, the thing you were telling me, which I found actually quite moving, You said one of the most, something that had brought you closer to the dimension of the supernatural than ever before was you went in 2019, you played mini golf in the center of the cathedral. In 2019, following in the footsteps of St. Justice and Bishop Gundolf, the cathedral authority set up a mini golf course in the nave of the cathedral. Can I tell people what you, so Tom texted me after he played golf in the cathedral.
这里，你可以看到它显然不是废墟。我们这里有一个标志，上面写着对人类不安全，下方有一百英尺的落差。一般来说，这——这是一个非常非常令人印象深刻的结构，这并不令人意外，因为在有非常重要的河流渡口的地方，你就会希望拥有非常强大的防御系统，以便能够保持对它的控制。因此，正如你所说，威廉在这里建造了第一座城堡也就不足为奇了，因为这就是诺曼人正在做的事情。同样，他把大教堂交给了奥多，他也让奥多建造一座城堡，奥多也照做了。它是木制的。但当奥多因行为恶劣并对同母异父的弟弟背信弃义而被赶走时，
and he said, Dominic, while playing adventure golf, I really felt that I, I reflected on the bridges that need to be built in our own lives and in the world today. And Dominic, you know what's amazing about that reflection that I had? Yeah. Is it a few days later, the diocese of Rochester put out a message saying that we hope that while playing adventure golf, visitors will reflect on the bridges that need to be built in their own lives and in our world today. So it's incredible.
他将城堡的责任交给了贡道夫主教。我们已经说过贡道夫是一位了不起的建筑师，一位了不起的工程师。他开始着手用石工建造一座城堡，这可能是诺曼人在征服后建造的第一批石造城堡之一。正因如此，我在来这里之前在博德利图书馆（Bodleian）查阅资料时发现，贡道夫显然被皇家工程兵部队公认为建立他们的人。所以他们将一条延续线一路追溯回中世纪，回到了贡道夫。我想这部分归功于伦敦塔的名声，但也归功于此，尽管我们现在站立的城堡主楼
Yet again, the Diocese of Rochester has been hacking our texts. Unbelievable. So on that bombshell, Tom, let's just move on very quickly to talk about Rochester Castle before we descend and allow the school children up here. Tell me about the history of Rochester Castle. So this is what, Norman originally? Yeah, so Defoe in that bit you read, I mean, he's very rude about the cathedral, perhaps not unfairly, but he said that the castle was just a ruin, which, I mean, we're standing
是在12世纪建造的，但城墙是贡道夫的。这座城堡主楼，我的意思是，太惊人了。当你坐火车进入罗切斯特时，你可以看到它巍然耸立。我认为它是英格兰最高的主楼，也是整个欧洲最高的主楼之一。同样，它不仅是由一位主教建造的，而且是由一位大主教建造的。罗切斯特在12世纪被交给了坎特伯雷大主教区。我们在节目中讨论过它。它曾出现在《历史的残余》中。确实如此。所以它曾出现在我们关于农民起义的节目中，虽然名字叫得不对，但这是埃塞克斯郡以及肯特郡人民的一场伟大叛乱。当叛军想要进军伦敦时，他们必须首先攻占城堡，因为它是通往伦敦的道路的伟大钥匙。他们成功地攻占了城堡并俘虏了城堡总管，也就是负责管理它的人。他们把他当做人质。当他们到达伦敦并想要与理查二世及其政府谈判时，罗切斯特大教堂的总管就是他们用来
up here, and you can see it's clearly not a ruin. we've got a sign there saying it's unsafe for humans a hundred foot drop beneath generally this i mean this is very very impressive structure um and it's not surprising because where you have um a very important river crossing you want to have a very strong defensive system so that you can keep control of it and so it's not surprising that as you say yes it is william who builds the first castle here because that's what the normans are doing um and again he gives that you know he's given the cathedral to Odo, he also tells Odo to build a castle, which Odo does. It's made of wood. But when Odo gets chucked out for behaving badly and treacherously towards his half-brother,
在叛军和皇室当局之间进行沟通的人。基本上，通过罗切斯特城堡的历史，很多大人物都曾来过这里，不是吗？所以法兰西国王约翰，当他被黑太子俘虏时，他被带过罗切斯特，并向大教堂进行了捐赠。是的。这很好。亨利五世，在从阿金库尔凯旋归来之后，你知道的，他必须到达加来，横渡到加来，骑马沿着大路前往罗切斯特，并穿过了罗切斯特。他并不是最后一个在罗切斯特进行难忘游行的国王，因为还有另一位在城市里留下了真正的印记。我们从这里看不到他留下的那个印记。
he hands the responsibility for the castle over to Bishop Gundulf. And we've said how Gundulf is a tremendous architect, a tremendous engineer. He gets to work building a castle out of stone masonry, probably one of the first stone castles to be built by the Normans after the conquest. And it's because of that, I was just reading up in the Bodleon before we came up here, that Gundulf apparently is recognised by the core of Royal Engineering as the man who established them. So they kind of trace a line of continuity all the way back to through the Middle Ages, back to Gundalph. And that I guess in part is due to the reputation of the Tower of London, but also due to this, because although the keep where we're standing,
无
now was built in the 12th century. The walls are Gandalf's. And this keep is, I mean, is amazing. When you come into Rochester on the train, you can see it kind of looming up. I think it's the tallest keep in England, one of the tallest keeps in the whole of Europe. And again, it was built by not just a bishop, but by an archbishop. So Rochester got given to the Archbishop Rick of Canterbury in the 12th century. We've had it in the show before. It's been in the rest of history. It has. So it featured in our episode on the Peasants Revolt, misnamed, but this great rebellion of people in Essex, but also in Kent. And when the rebels want to march on London, they have to seize the castle first because it's the great key to the road that leads to London. And they manage to storm the castle and they capture the Castellan, the guy in charge of it. And they take him hostage. And when they get to London and they want to negotiate, with Richard II and his government, the Castellan of Rochester Cathedral is the guy that they use
to communicate between the rebels and the royal authorities. And basically, through Rochester Castle's history, loads of big names have been here, haven't they? So King John of France, when he was captured by the Black Prince, he was brought through Rochester, made a donation to the cathedral. Yes. That's nice. Henry V, after returning in triumph from Agincourt, you know, he has to get to Calais, crosses to Calais rides the great road up to London and passes through Rochester. And he is not the last king to make a memorable procession through Rochester because there is another one who has left a real mark on the city. We can't see that mark that he left from up here.
无
So I think we should wind our way down the stairs past the sobbing schoolchildren and allow them to come up here to the top and we will go down and go to this site, which commemorates the arrival in Rochester in 1660 of Charles II. Tom, Restoration House, Rochester. That's where we are right now. An absolutely gorgeous example of 17th century architecture. We've just been shown around by the owner, Jonathan Wilmot, amazing artworks, furniture and whatnot that you can see if you're watching on Spotify or on YouTube. But why are we here? Well, as you say, an amazing 17th century house. Origins going back to late 15th century, 16th century, all kind of patched together. So Pevesner rather rudely
所以我想我们应该顺着楼梯走下去，经过那些呜咽的学童，让他们上来，而我们则往下走去这个地方，这里纪念的是1660年查理二世抵达罗切斯特。汤姆，复辟楼，罗切斯特。我们现在就在这里。这是一处绝佳的17世纪建筑典范。我们刚刚在主人乔纳森·威尔莫特的带领下参观了这里，里面有惊人的艺术品、家具等等，如果你在Spotify或YouTube上观看就能看到。但我们为什么会在这里？嗯，如你所说，这是一座惊人的17世纪房屋。起源可以追溯到15世纪末、16世纪，经过各种拼凑。因此佩夫斯纳很不客气地
described it as being all highly peculiar and undisciplined. But I think it's unbelievably atmospheric, very different vibe to being on top of a Norman castle. But we are here because the most famous person who stayed here was Charles II, who had been in exile throughout the restoration. Cromwell dies. People don't know what to do, so they say, well, let's try and bring Charles II back. So he lands in Dover. He's been staying in the Dutch Republic. Now he's back in English soil, and he's processing towards London, and he spends the night of 28th of May, 1660 here. And the next morning he gets up, it's his birthday, and he goes off into London. And so hence the name, Restoration House.
将其形容为非常奇特且毫无章法。但我觉得它有着难以置信的氛围，与站在诺曼城堡顶上的感觉有着非常不同的氛围。但我们之所以来到这里，是因为住在这里最著名的人物是查理二世，他在复辟期间一直流亡在外。克伦威尔去世了。人们不知道该怎么办，于是他们说，好吧，让我们试着把查理二世迎回来。于是他在多佛登陆。他之前一直住在荷兰共和国。现在他回到了英格兰的土地上，正向伦敦进发，并在1660年5月28日这一晚住在这里。第二天早上他起床，正好是他的生日，然后他就前往伦敦。因此得名“复辟楼”。
But there's a brilliant literary connection, isn't there? And a connection with one of Rochester's, one of this area's favourite sons. Because am I not right in saying that Charles Dickens used this house where we're sitting right now as the inspiration for Satis House, which is, of course, Miss Havisham's house in his novel Great Expectations? I think for the purposes of this podcast, we can say 100%. This was the inspiration. It has said that. No, no. Dickens was seen leaning on a kind of, looking in at it while writing great expectations. I think we can say 100%. And it actually, for those who are looking on YouTube or Spotify, if you imagine this setting covered in cobwebs and a mouldering wedding cake in the background, I think you can absolutely imagine Ms. Havisham jilted at the altar and had a cade wedding dress kind of gliding around like a ghoul, poor Pip, you know, the little blacksmith's boy, feeling. very coarse and sorry for himself.
但这里有一个极棒的文学渊源，对吧？以及与罗切斯特当地、这个地区最受欢迎之子之一的渊源。因为我是不是可以说，查理二世住过这座我们现在正坐着的房子，被查尔斯·狄更斯用作了“饱经沧桑之屋”（Satis House）的灵感来源？当然，也就是他的小说《远大前程》中哈维什姆小姐的房子。我想对于这个播客的目的来说，我们可以说是100%。这就是灵感来源。人们是这么说的。不，不。有人看到狄更斯靠在某种地方，往里面张望，同时写下了《远大前程》。我想我们可以说是100%。而且实际上，对于那些在YouTube或Spotify上观看的人来说，如果你想象这个场景布满蜘蛛网，背景里还有一个发霉的婚礼蛋糕，我想你绝对可以想象哈维什姆小姐在圣坛前被抛弃，穿着一件发黄的婚纱像幽灵一样滑行，可怜的皮普，你知道的，那个铁匠铺的小男孩，感觉非常粗俗且自怨自艾。
Well, Great Expectations are very close to my heart, Tom, because I want the school public speaking and reading competition four years in a row with the opening of Great Expectations. Four years in a row? Four years in a row with the same reading. God. Joyless. Are you allowed to do that? Not really.
好吧，《远大前程》对我来说意义非凡，汤姆，因为我曾连续四年凭借《远大前程》的开场白赢得学校的公共演讲和朗读比赛。连续四年？连续四年用同一篇朗读。天哪。真无趣。你被允许这么做吗？其实不太行。
It was considered against the spirit, but not the letter of the law. I really does seem like cheating. By about the third or fourth time, the head of English said, you're really ruining this for everybody else with this reading that is a lot. unbeatable because it's such a brilliant reading. But you must be excited, though, to be here. Oh, yeah. I mean, but you know, you come home.
这被认为违背了精神，但没有违背字面法律。这看起来真的很像作弊。大约到第三或第四次时，英语系主任说：“你用这篇无人能敌的朗读，真的把其他所有人的体验都给毁了，因为这段朗读太棒了。”但来到这里，你一定很兴奋吧？哦，是的。我的意思是，但你知道的，你回到了家。
That's the way I roll, Tom. That's the way I operate. If I can win and suck all the pleasure out of it for other people, so much the better. Let's talk about Dickens. The reason that he's kind of hanging out here gazing at the windows is because he actually had a house just outside, Rochester, the other side of the Medway, which was called Gads Hill Place. Yeah.
我就是这样的人，汤姆。我就是这样行事的。如果我能赢，并把别人的所有乐趣都榨干，那就再好不过了。我们来谈谈狄更斯吧。他之所以在这里闲逛并凝视着窗户，是因为他在罗切斯特郊外，也就是梅德威河的另一边，实际上有一栋房子，叫做加兹山庄。是的。
And he lived there for the last 14 years of his life. And he absolutely loved Rochester. Basically, everywhere you go in Rochester, you see Dickens illusions. So restaurants, cafes, whatever. We'd just been to the cafe, Jaggers. Yeah, and there are kind of a little sign saying Dickens, you know, this house was where so-and-so lived or whatever. And Gads Hill, the house outside Rochester where he lived, he got given a Swiss chalet by one of his friends. And it kind of arrived like an IKEA pack in various boxes.
他在那里度过了他人生的最后14年。他非常喜欢罗切斯特。基本上你在罗切斯特到处都能看到狄更斯的痕迹。比如餐厅、咖啡馆等等。我们刚刚去过贾格尔斯咖啡馆。是的，那里有一些写着“狄更斯”的小牌子，你知道的，这栋房子是某某住过的地方之类的。加兹山，也就是罗切斯特郊外他住的那栋房子，他的一个朋友送给他一个瑞士木屋。它就像一个宜家包装盒一样，分成各种箱子送到了。
and Dickens wanted to assemble it at a viewpoint where he could look out at the sea. So the bottom of his garden, there was quite a busy road. So he dug a tunnel under the road and then he assembled the Swiss chalet on the far side of the road. So that in the second floor where he had his study, he could look out at the sea and be inspired by it. And that chalet, apparently, is still, you can still see it just off Rochester High Street. So if you like Dickens, I mean, there's no end of Dickensian. facts here. And the other famous thing associated with Dickens here is that it's the setting for his last novel, which he never completed the mystery of Edwin Drood, and the opium
狄更斯想把它组装在一个能够远眺大海的观景台上。所以他的花园底部有一条相当繁忙的马路。于是他在马路底下挖了一条隧道，然后在马路的另一边组装了那个瑞士木屋。这样在他有书房的二楼，他就可以眺望大海并从中获得灵感。而据我所知，那个木屋现在依然还在，就在罗切斯特高街附近。所以如果你喜欢狄更斯，我的意思是，这里有数不尽的狄更斯式的情节。这里与狄更斯相关的另一个著名之处在于，它是他最后一部未完成的小说《爱德温·德鲁德之谜》的背景地，而那个鸦片
addict and cathedral organist, John Jasper, who almost certainly is the murderer of Edwin Drood, or is Edwin Drew dead, who knows. He lived on one of the gates that's just below the castle where we've been. And the Rochester in Edwin Drood is called Cloisterham. And the, you Dickens' description of it is very similarly to foe. So he says a city of another and a bygone time is close to him. All things in it are of the past. So there's that
瘾君子兼大教堂管风琴师约翰·贾斯珀，几乎可以肯定是爱德温·德鲁德的谋杀犯，或者说爱德温·德鲁德到底死没死，谁知道呢。他就住在我们刚刚去过的城堡下方的其中一座城门上。在《爱德温·德鲁德》中，罗切斯特被称为克洛斯特勒姆。而且，你狄更斯对它的描述与现实非常相似。所以他说：一个属于另一个过去时代的城市紧挨着它。这里的一切都属于过去。所以有一种
sense of Rochester as a place where you know, the history of England is invested. The layers of history. But as Dickens also knew, the same cannot be said of Chatham. And he knew Chatham very well because he had spent the formative years of his childhood there. And that's because
罗切斯特的感觉，在这里你知道，英格兰的历史被深深注入其中。历史的层层叠叠。但正如狄更斯也知道的那样，查塔姆可不能这么说。而且他对查塔姆非常熟悉，因为他童年成型的岁月就是在那里度过的。那是由于
his father, John Dickens, had worked as a clerk there, hadn't he, the naval payoff? And so Dickens lived there from what, the age of five to the age of 11? Yes. And thought it was wonderful. Yeah. Had beautiful kind of incredible childhood memories of it, thought it was amazing. And then years later, in 1860, when he was 48, he came back.
他的父亲约翰·狄更斯曾在那里当过职员，不是吗，就是海军薪饷处的职员？所以狄更斯从几岁到几岁住在那里，从五岁到十一岁？是的。并且觉得那里棒极了。是的。对那里有着美好得不可思议的童年回忆，觉得它amazing。然后多年以后，在1860年，他48岁时，他又回来了。
And, you know, it was his first visit to Chatham since he'd been a boy. And he wrote up about it expressing essentially his disappointment that it wasn't quite as amazing as he remembered it. And he was so disappointed. And listeners to this podcast will be thrilled to know this, that he called Chatham Dullesborough. So maybe we could use that as the title for this episode. But then after a day touring, Chatham, aka Dalsborough, he left in a slightly more benignant mood. So he wrote, when I went alone to the railway to catch my train, I was in a more charitable mood with Dahlbara than I had been all day. And yet in my heart, I had loved it all day too. Who was I that I should quarrel with the town for being changed to me? When I myself had come back, so changed to it. All my early readings and early imaginations dated from this place, and I took them away so full of innocent construction and garrulous belief, and I brought them back so worn and torn, so much
而且，你知道的，这是他自童年以来第一次访问查塔姆。他对此写了文章，基本上表达了他的失望，因为这里并不像他记忆中那么amazing。他非常失望，而这个播客的听众听到这个一定会兴奋不已，他把查塔姆称为“无聊堡”（Dullesborough）。所以也许我们可以用这个作为这一集节目的标题。但在游览了查塔姆（又名道尔斯伯勒）一天之后，他带着稍微更加温和的心情离开了。于是他写道：当我独自一人去火车站赶火车时，我对道尔斯伯勒的心情比一整天都要宽容。然而在我的内心中，这一整天我也同样深爱着它。我是谁啊，竟要和一个对我而言已经物是人非的城镇争吵不休？当我回到它身边时，自己也已变得如此面目全非。我所有的早期阅读和早期想象都源于这个地方，我带着它们离开时，里面充满了天真的构建和滔滔不绝的信仰；而当我把它们带回来时，它们却已如此破旧不堪，饱经沧桑，变得如此世故，却也变得如此糟糕。哦，汤姆，这太美了。这是一段很美的朗读，实际上这也激发了我想去查塔姆的愿望。所以我想我们应该离开复辟楼了。我必须说，这是一栋多么惊人的房子，我们受到了多么皇室般的照顾。实际上，我想我并没有夸张，当我说，我不认为我曾去过任何一个历史遗迹比复辟楼更让我享受，且能在我的记忆中存留更久的了。好吧，你知道吗，我正坐在你对面看着你。你坐在一把宏伟的古董扶手椅上，你身后是一个滴答作响的老式落地钟。我某种程度上觉得，对于《余下的历史》的每一次录音，你都应该保持这种氛围。我想我本来就已经这样了，不是吗？我觉得你并没有完全这样。
the wiser, and so much the worse. Oh, Tom, that's lovely. That's a lovely reading, and actually that inspires me to go to Chatham. So I think we should head off from Restoration House. I have to say, what an amazing house this is and how royally we've been looked after. I actually, I don't think I'm exaggerating when I say, I don't think I've ever been to a location with the rest of history that I have enjoyed more and that will live in my memory for longer than Restoration House. Well, do you know, I'm sat here looking at you. You're in a magnificent period armchair behind you as a ticking grandfather clock. I kind of think you should have this vibe for every recording of the rest of's history. I think I do already, no? I don't think you do quite.
哦，真让人失望。不过话说回来，说到积极向上的氛围，让我们出发去查塔姆高街吧。本集节目由Uber赞助播出。现在，你知道那种当你在最需要的时候，有人为你挺身而出的感觉吗？我们有时都需要那样，Uber深知这一点。Uber不仅仅是一次行程或一顿外卖，它代表着无论如何都会为你挺身而出。就像对于你的远方朋友，在他们生病时送上热汤，在他们低落时送去鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么，你
Oh, disappointing. But anyway, talking of positive vibes, let's off head off to Chatham High Street. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered, it's showing up no matter what. Like for your long-distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you.
都会出现。只要有心，我们就在路上。Uber，在路上。今天就下载应用程序吧。本集节目由Folio Society赞助播出。现在，托马斯，你知道的，在中古时期，如果你是一个僧侣，制作一本手稿可能需要花上你几年的时间。你必须逐字逐句地把它抄写下来，然后在那之后，页边空白处就会准备好，你会在空白处添加各种装饰元素和各种金箔之类的东西。然后，它看起来就会棒极了。所以通常可能需要几年时间才能完成，但成品却能保存几个世纪。这几乎就是Folio Society今天在做的事情，当然，只不过用的羊皮纸略少，羽毛笔也更少。是的，Folio Society精选了一些有史以来最伟大的
show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. This episode is brought to you by the Folio Society. Now, Thomas, you know, in the Middle Ages, it could take you years if you're a monk to create a manuscript. You'd have to copy it out, word by word, and then after all that, the margins would be ready, and you'd put all kind of decorative elements and all kinds of gills and stuff in the margins. And then, it would look fantastic. So it might take often years to finish, but the finished product would then last for centuries. And that is pretty much what the Folio Society does today, only, of course, with slightly less parchment and fewer quills. Yes, the Folio Society takes some of the greatest
著作，比如乔治·奥威尔的《1984》、J.R.托尔金的作品，或是弗兰克·赫伯特的《沙丘》，他们的编辑、设计师和工匠团队精心制作出如此精美的书籍。它们本身就像是艺术品。因此每一本都经过精心设计，配有精美的书套、屡获殊荣的插图，以及向书中故事致敬的封面。它不仅仅是保护它们。所以如果你像我和汤姆一样，认为一本书的装帧应该和它的内容一样精彩，那么Folio Society绝对说出了你的心声。探索世界上最受喜爱的故事，以最美丽的形态呈现，尽在foliosociety.com。网址是foliosociety.com。
works ever written, things like George Orwell's 1984, or the quests in J.R. Tolkien or Frank Herbert's June and their team of editors and designers and artisans. They craft books that are so beautiful. They're like works of art in their own right. So each one is carefully designed with slipcases, award-winning illustrations, and covers that honor the stories inside. It doesn't just protect them. So if like me and like Tom, you think that a book should look as good as it reads, then the Folio Society very much speaks your language. Explore the world's most loved stories in the most beautiful form, only at foliosociety.com. That is foliosociety.com.
欢迎回到《余下的历史》。非常令人兴奋的是，我们现在已经从罗切斯特搬到了查塔姆。汤姆，让我们顺着这个可爱的小坡走上去，讨论一下你为什么把我们带到这里。好吧，多米尼克，如果你看这里，上面写着：甘多夫路（Gundolph Road）。所以我们正走在甘多夫路上。甘多夫，这个节目的老朋友，皇家工程学的奠基人，威廉一世最器重的主教，设计了罗切斯特大教堂和城堡的人。他也把手伸向了查塔姆，因为尽管查塔姆在很大程度上是一个18世纪、19th世纪的地方，那是它的全盛时期，但在中世纪这里曾有一个村庄，甘多夫为穷人和麻风病人建立了一家医院，
Welcome back to the rest is history. And very excitingly, we have now moved from Rochester to Chatham. Tom, let's walk up this lovely little slope here and discuss why you brought us here. Well, Dominic, if you look here, it reads, Gundolph Road. So we are on Gundolf Road. Gundulf, very much friend of the show, the founder of the Royal Engineers, William I first's go-to bishop, the guy who designed Rochester Cathedral and the castle. And he got his hands on Chatham as well, because although Chatham is very much a kind of 18th century, 19th century place, that's its heyday, there was a village here in the Middle Ages and Gundal founded a hospital for the poor and lepros,
他们会沿着河被带过来，而河就在下面，然后会有一些特殊的通道从河边延伸上来，把他们带到医院，因为没有人愿意跟麻风病人接触，而且只有麻风病人被允许走这些通道。医院早已不复存在，但它留下了唯一的一处遗迹，就是我们现在看到的这座小教堂。所以小教堂的正面，显然非常维多利亚风格。
and they would be brought along the river, which is just down there, and then there would be kind of special passageways that would thread up from the river to bring them to the hospital because nobody wanted to come in touch with the leper, and only the lepros were allowed to go up these. The hospital is long gone, but there is one remainder of it, and it is this chapel that we're looking at here. So the front of the chapel, clearly very Victorian.
这是吉尔伯特·斯科特爵士的作品，他设计了阿尔伯特纪念碑、外交和联邦事务部以及新哥特式维多利亚风格的这些伟大纪念碑。但如果我们绕到后面，就会发现12世纪原初小教堂的一部分。我喜欢这样想：尽管我们身处查塔姆的心脏地带，身处21st世纪英国的喧嚣之中，也许在这座小教堂内部，有一个小小的避难所，一个
This is by Sir Gilbert Scott, who designed the Albert Memorial and the Foreign and Commonwealth Office and these kind of great monuments of Neo-Gothic Victoriana. But if we go round the back, we will find a bit of the original 12th century chapel. And I like to think that even though we are here in the heart of Chatham, the swirl of 21st century Britain, maybe inside this chapel, there is a little haven, a little
对信仰时代的微小提醒。我们将看看里面有什么。你可以看到这个入口。东部区域，仍然保留着12世纪原初小教堂的碎片。所以如果我们从这里进去，我们可以看到，因为我想这里会有一种修道院般的平静气氛，也许在查塔姆的喧嚣之中，是对中世纪精神性的一种提醒。而且我认为这对人们来说会非常触动。所以让我们去看看里面在发生什么。所以这可能不太是我所期望的。所以我们也许应该向人们描述一下
reminder of the age of faith. And we will see what we find inside. You can see this entrance. The eastern section, there are still bits of the original 12th century chapel. So if we go in through here, we can see, you know, because I imagine that there'll be a kind of a mood of cloistered peace, maybe amid the hurly-burly of Chatham, a reminder of the spirituality of the Middle Ages. And I think it'll be very moving for people. So let's go and see what's going on. So this is maybe not quite what I was expecting. So we should maybe describe for people.
我们正在看到的。这对我来说，非常能说明中世纪的精神性。大约有四个人正在地上扭打和缠斗。所以如果你没有在Spotify或YouTube上观看，这就是我所看到的。基本上是一个人的大腿缠在另一个人的脖子上。在他们身后有两个标牌，上面写着“花岗岩健身房”（Granite Gym）。这座古老的圣殿、中世纪精神性的宝库，似乎变成了一个健身房。所以我想这大概不是甘多夫主教想要的，但无所谓了。是的。这就是进步。
we're seeing. This, to me, very much speaks of medieval spirituality. There are about four people writhing and grappling on the ground. So if you're not watching on Spotify or YouTube, that's what I'm looking at. Basically, somebody's thighs and they're wrapped around another person's neck. And behind them are two signs reading Granite Gym. And this ancient sanctuary, this repository of medieval spirituality, seems to have become a gym. So I like to think that this probably isn't what Bishop Gundolf wanted, but whatever. Yeah. It's progress.
我确信他在这里与基督进行过一番摔跤。不过多米尼克，我只是想说那是，哈利，在你身后，那就是12世纪小教堂的遗迹。所以基本上，对于那些没有观看视频的人来说，汤姆正指着一截墙壁，那扇可爱、可爱的窗户。我真的不知道该说什么了，汤姆。你想向大家描述一下吗？好吧，我要说的是，没有人在
I'm sure he did a bit of wrestling with Christ here. But Dominic, just to say that is the, so Harry, behind you, that is what remains of the 12th century chapel. So basically, for those people not watching, Tom is pointing at a bit of wall, the lovely, lovely window. I don't know what else to say, really, Tom. Do you want to describe it to this? Well, what I will say is that there aren't people kind of wrestling. underneath the under that so maybe showing a bit of respect there is a
那个……下方扭打，所以也许表现出了一点尊重，那里有一个
sofa isn't that broken till so that's good there is so anyway that's progress so we have crossed the street and we've come a little bit further forward in time so we're now standing for those people who are not watching on YouTube or Spotify we are standing
沙发，不是还没坏吗，所以挺好的，有……总之，那是进步。所以我们穿过了街道，在时间上又向前迈进了一点点。所以我们现在正站在，对于那些没有在YouTube或Spotify上观看的人来说，我们正站在
in front of some lovely little brick arms houses and Tom these were built in 1592 and they're associated with a very famous name in kind of Tudor seafaring history. Yes, so this is the hospital of Sir John Hawkins in Chatham. It is the single oldest Royal Navy charity, the oldest Royal Navy Hospital. And it was founded by Sir John Hawkins, who was a cousin of Sir Francis Drake.
一些可爱的小砖砌阿尔姆斯豪斯（救济院）前面。汤姆，这些建于1592年，它们与都铎航海史上一个非常著名的名字有关。是的，这就是查塔姆的约翰·霍金斯爵士医院。它是英国皇家海军现存最古老的慈善机构，最古老的皇家海军医院。它由约翰·霍金斯爵士创立，他是弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士的表亲。
He was first the treasurer of Elizabeth's Navy, then its controller. He played a key role in establishing. not just Chatham, but at the English Navy as a force to be reckoned with. And in his will, he set aside some property to endow a hospital, which makes him sound one of history's good guys. But there is a slight complication which is hinted at on the website for the Hospital of Sir John Hawkins, where it confesses that a lot of the money that Sir John Hawkins made, which enabled him to fund this hospital
他最初是伊丽莎白女王海军的财务长，后来成为审计长。他在确立不仅是查塔姆，而且是整个英国海军成为一支不可忽视的力量方面发挥了关键作用。他在遗嘱中拨出了一些财产来资助一家医院，这让他听起来像是历史上的好人之一。但这里有一个小小的复杂之处，约翰·霍金斯爵士医院的网站上对此作出了暗示，其中坦白说，约翰·霍金斯爵士用来资助这家医院的大量资金，
was made in the slave trade and so this disavowal is made although not out of step with the societal norms of his time the governors fully acknowledge the abhorrent and brutal nature of this vile activity and regret Sir John's involvement profoundly and then there's a kind of big
都是通过奴隶贸易赚取的。因此做出了这种撇清，尽管这并不违背他那个时代的社会规范，但理事会成员完全承认这一卑劣活动的令人厌恶和残酷性质，并对霍金斯爵士的参与表示深切的遗憾。然后这里有一个巨大的
however he was an outstanding seaman navigator, naval administrator and benefactor of naval veterans and both of those things are clearly true and so this is absolutely the kind of place that focuses some of the ambivalences and complexities of Britain's...
转折，然而，他是一位杰出的海员、航海家、海军行政官和海军退伍军人的慈善家。这两点显然都是真的。所以这绝对是一个集中体现了英国……的矛盾性和复杂性的地方。
Everybody loves focusing on ambivalence on. And he's a great Spanish Armada man, isn't he? All of that. I mean, he's roughs, roughs, beards, you know, playing bowls, all of that. Yes, I mean, he's, you know, he is one of the great kind of,
每个人都喜欢关注矛盾性。而且他是个伟大的西班牙无敌舰队英雄，对吧？诸如此类。我的意思是，他是那种粗犷、留着胡子、玩地掷球的人，全都是那样。是的，我的意思是，他是，你知道的，他是伟大的……之一，
the Victorians loved him. They loved the kind of idea that the sea dogs of, under Elizabeth I first, had been the prototype for Britain's Navy. And this place had a, tremendous history of sea doggery or sea dogging, didn't it? Because there's a lot of sea dogging going on here.
维多利亚时代的人非常崇拜他。他们热爱那种伊丽莎白一世统治下的小海狗（Sea dogs）是英国海军雏型的这种想法。这个地方有着一段了不起的海狗历史或“海狗行为”（sea dogging），对吧？因为这里有很多海狗行为。
They had two veterans at the Battle of Copenhagen who were here. And a veteran of Trafalgar lived here, right? Yes. A guy called Henry Dawkins was here. Now, you said that this was built in the Tudor period. These are not Tudor building. So actually, it got rebuilt in 1789. Right.
这里曾有过两位参加过哥本哈根战役的老兵。而且还有一个特拉法加海战的老兵在这里住过，对吧？是的。一个叫亨利·道金斯的人曾在这里。现在，你刚才说这是在都铎时期建造的。这些可不是都铎时期的建筑。实际上，它们在1789年进行了重建。对的。
And then it got refurbished again in the 1980s. when it got opened by the Queen Mother. Oh, I love it. So you've got John Hawkins, you've got redevelopment in the period of the French Revolution, and you've got the Queen Mother. And I think that, Dominant, you'd agree, that this is one of the many jewels of Chatham High Street.
然后它们在20世纪80年代再次进行了翻新，当时由王太后主持了揭幕仪式。哦，我太喜欢了。所以你有约翰·霍金斯，有法国大革命时期的重建，还有王太后。我想，多米尼克，你会同意，这是查塔姆高街众多明珠之一。
That's the rich tapestry of British history, right? But the exciting news is, there are more jewels. And I think we should go and look. So let's go. That was so weak. So a really weak clap there from The to start this new segment. Now, Tom, one of the things
这就是英国历史丰富多彩的织锦，对吧？但令人兴奋的消息是，还有更多的明珠。我想我们应该去看看。我们走吧。真是软弱无力。这节目的掌声真是太软弱了，为了开启这个新环节。现在，汤姆，我们
that we associate with Dockland areas, of course, is pubs. And we are looking at two splendid historic pubs. So one of them is the North Forland. And I just want to give people an impression of their forensic research that you've brought to this episode.
把码头区和什么联系在一起呢？当然是酒吧。我们现在正看着两家光彩夺目的历史悠久的酒吧。其中一家是“北福克兰”（North Foreland）。我只是想让大家对你为这一集所做的深入细致的研究留下一个印象。
Yeah. So your notes say, Nelson reputedly drank here. So that's great. So that definitely happened. So I read that it was rebuilt in 1912 and shut in 2012. So an amazing...
是的。所以你的笔记上写着：纳尔逊传说曾在这里饮酒。太棒了。所以这绝对发生过。所以我读到它在1912年重建，并在2012年关闭。真是一个惊人的……
So I bet you're glad you've seen that now. Imagine if you'd been stuck in the Cotswolds all this time and you've never got to see that. A really amazing history. There's more, isn't that? Yeah, there's more. You have not yet drunk your fill of the cup of historical delights that Chatham High Street has to offer. So do you want to continue or are you laughing too much? No, I'm laughing too much, but I will continue.
所以我打赌你现在很高兴看到这个了。想象一下，如果你一直被困在科茨沃尔德，你永远也看不到这个。一段真正惊人的历史。还有更多，对吧？是的，还有更多。你还没有喝足查塔姆高街所能提供的历史乐趣之杯。所以你是想继续，还是笑得太厉害了？不，我笑得太厉害了，但我会继续的。
So opposite us is something called the Ship Inn. And I read in Tom's notes, Tom's written the words, the words, one of the words. the oldest gay pubs in the country. I think that's definitely true. But then his citation comes from Kenton. I'm laughing so much I can't speak. Kent Online is a very reputable source.
所以我们对面的是一家叫“船只客栈”（Ship Inn）的酒吧。我在汤姆的笔记里读到，汤姆写下了这样的话：“全国最古老的同性恋酒吧之一”。我想这绝对是真的。但随后他的引文来自“肯特在线”（Kenton Online）。我笑得太厉害都说不出话来了。“肯特在线”是一个非常靠谱的信源。
Very scholarly, peer-reviewed. So do you want to read that what it says? Kent Online. Apparently. I feel like the word apparently is doing a lot of lifting there. It gets better, doesn't it? apparently the bartender's mate recently compiled a history of Rochester High Street
非常学术，经过同行评审。所以你想读一下上面写的内容吗？“肯特在线”。显然。我觉得“显然”这个词在那里起到了很大的作用。情况越来越好了，对吧？据报道，酒保的搭档最近整理了一份罗切斯特高街的历史，
and proudly informed me this is the writer from Kent Online that the pub is more than 500 years old and Medway's oldest gay bar well that's definitely true not only this but he confidently declared that the purple dance bar on the left complete with its brick look wallpaper was the site of the first arrested conviction for buggery way back in the days of Henry the 8th. So apparently, that from... According to the Barman's mate.
并自豪地通知我——这是“肯特在线”的记者——这家酒吧有500多年的历史，是梅德威最古老的同性恋酒吧。嗯，这绝对是真的。不仅如此，他还自信地宣称，左侧带有砖墙壁纸的紫色舞厅，正是早在亨利八世时期因鸡奸罪而被捕并定罪的第一起案件的发生地。所以显然，根据……据酒保的搭档所说。
The Barman's mates. But actually, there's some serious history behind us, much as I'm laughing about your ludicrous research, there's some serious history behind us that I'm hoping you've put an equal amount of effort into. Well, actually, do you know what I'm going to do? I'm going to read from the foundation stone on this building. Which reads, this foundation stone was laid by Simon Magnus for a memorial synagogue in affectionate remembrance of his much lamented and only son Lazarus Simon Magnus Esquire.
酒保的搭档。但实际上，我们身后有一些严肃的历史，尽管我正嘲笑你那荒谬的研究，但我们身后确实有一些严肃的历史，我希望你在这些历史上付出了同等程度的努力。好吧，实际上，你知道我要做什么吗？我要宣读这栋建筑上的奠基石。
So a synagogue on Chatham High Street is a reminder of the fact that, as well as pubs, what you expect to find in, you know, Docklands and Dockyards and all that kind of thing, is lots of people from overseas. And when the Jews were allowed back into England in the mid-17th century, by Oliver Cromwell. My friend of the show, Oliver Cromwell. Although not officially, but effectively. One of the earliest communities outside London where Jews settled was in Chatham, because of course it was growing. It was provided links to all the other Jewish communities on the continent. And the first synagogue on this site was built in 1750,
上面写着：这块奠基石由西蒙·马格纳斯为纪念纪念犹太会堂而安放，深切缅怀他备受哀悼的独子拉撒路·西蒙·马格纳斯先生。所以，查塔姆高街上的一座犹太会堂提醒着我们这样一个事实：除了酒吧之外，你在码头区、造船厂和所有这类地方期望找到的，还有大量来自海外的人。当犹太人在17世纪中期被奥利弗·克伦威尔重新允许回到英格兰时。我的节目老朋友，奥利弗·克伦威尔。虽然不是官方允许，但实际上如此。伦敦以外犹太人最早定居的社区之一就在查塔姆，因为这里当然在不断发展。它提供了通往欧洲大陆所有其他犹太人社区的联系。这里的第一个犹太会堂建于1750年，
and the people who were able to fund it could do it because they were helping people in the Royal Navy who had captured prizes to then kind of sell them, to get to convert it into money. they would take a cut, and that cut then enabled them to fund the first synagogue. But this particular synagogue opened in 1869, and it was, as the foundation said, it was built by the father of this guy, Simon Magnus, who had been a captain in the fourth Kent Artillery Volunteers, and he'd also been a business partner of Isambard Kingdom Brunel, the great engineer. So, you know, Gundulf, Brunel, all the great engineers are featuring in this story.
而能够资助它的人之所以能做到这一点，是因为他们一直在帮助皇家海军中捕获战利品的人将战利品出售，并将其转化为金钱。他们会从中抽成，而这笔抽成使他们能够资助建造第一座犹太会堂。但这座特定的犹太会堂于1869年开放，正如奠基石所言，它是这个人——西蒙·马格纳斯的父亲建造的，西蒙·马格纳斯曾是第四肯特炮兵志愿军的上尉，他也是伟大工程师伊桑巴德·金德姆·布鲁内尔的商业伙伴。所以，你知道的，甘多夫、布鲁内尔，所有伟大的工程师都在这个故事中登场了。
and we mentioned earlier about the leper hospital and about how there are these paths that go from the river up to where the hospital was and there was one of them that went along the west side of the synagogue so it was a kind of freehold of a strip of ground which remains kind of you know they couldn't buy it and they have to this day they have to pay a rent to use it of 5p per annum so again a kind of fascinating link taking us back to the medieval origins yet more of the extraordinarily rich and vibrant history of this part of the world yes absolutely and and this synagogue is still going strong and during both the wars particularly in the second world war it provided a home for jewish servicemen who passed through chatham and were working here so we've talked about nelson we've talked about um the second world war and the obvious place in chatham and
我们之前提到了麻风病人医院，以及那些从河边通往医院所在地的道路，其中有一条沿着犹太会堂的西侧延伸，所以这是一块长条形土地的永久产权，依然保留着，你知道的，他们当时无法买下它，直到今天他们每年仍需支付5便士的租金来使用它。所以这又是一个迷人的联系，把我们带回了中世纪的起源，以及这个世界这一地区极其丰富和充满活力的历史。是的，绝对的。而且这座犹太会堂至今依然生机勃勃，在两次世界大战期间，特别是在二战期间，它为路过查塔姆并在那里工作的犹太军人提供了一个家。所以我们谈到了纳尔逊，我们谈到了二战，而查塔姆显而易见的地方在于，
Chatham, where Nelson and the Second World War could join is the naval dockyards, the Royal Dockyards, the reason that all these incredible treasures, Dominic, are lining Chatham High Street. So I think that we should go there now. Let's do that. Right. Now, if you're watching this, you can see that we've moved location to somewhere very, very spectacular indeed. So, Tom, we have moved to Chatham's Royal Dockyard. and we're in the bowels of the dockyard and a place we will reveal in a second. So the dockyard is built in
查塔姆，纳尔逊和二战交汇的地方就是海军造船厂，皇家造船厂，也就是所有这些令人难以置信的珍宝——多米尼克——排列在查塔姆高街两侧的原因。所以我想我们现在应该去那里。我们去吧。好的。现在，如果你正在观看这个视频，你可以看到我们已经换了一个非常、非常壮观的地方。所以，汤姆，我们已经搬到了查塔姆的皇家造船厂，我们现在身处造船厂的腹地，这是一个我们稍后会揭晓的地方。所以造船厂建于
first opens in 1567 and last for what? 414 years. Wow. Okay. Yeah, it closes in 1984. So you love this place. Now, the irony is that when we first did the rest of history,
最早于1567年开放，持续了多久？414年。哇。好吧。是的，它在1984年关闭。所以你很喜欢这个地方。现在，具有讽刺意味的是，当我们第一次做《余下的历史》时，
you hated the Royal Navy, you hated dockyards. I hated rope. And above all, you hated rope. So it's fitting that to apologize and to abase yourself, you have come to the ropery of the Royal Dock I'll just talk to me about the raw dot com before we get on to the ropery.
你讨厌皇家海军，你讨厌造船厂。我讨厌绳索。最重要的是，你讨厌绳索。所以为了道歉和向自己谢罪，你来到了皇家造船厂的制绳厂。跟我讲讲制绳厂之前，先聊聊皇家造船厂吧。
I do love the dockyard here in Chatham. And the reason for that, it's a phrase that NAM Roger, the great historian of the Royal Navy, expressed, that the dockyards, Portsmouth, Chatham, places like that are 19th century islands in an 18th century sea. And you actually did, you did a TV show here on HG Wells. And I guess you came here because that sense of, it has a science fiction quality. It's this idea of technology being ahead of the historical context, because these are amazing places. These are where the most lethal killing machines on the face of the planet are developed, namely the ships of the Royal Navy, of which over the course of the 414 years, over 500 ships are built here, including the most famous of all HMS victory.
我真的很喜欢查塔姆的造船厂。原因在于皇家海军伟大历史学家楠·罗杰（NAM Rodger）表达过的一个短语，即造船厂——朴茨茅斯、查塔姆这类地方——是18世纪海洋中的19世纪岛屿。你实际上在这里做过一个关于H.G.威尔斯的电视节目。我想你来这里是因为那种感觉，它有一种科幻小说的特质。这就是技术领先于历史背景的想法，因为这些都是了不起的地方。这里是地球上开发最具杀伤力的杀戮机器的地方，也就是皇家海军的舰船。在过去的414年里，这里建造了500多艘舰船，其中包括最著名的HMS胜利号。
Yeah, so Tom, our old friend Daniel Defoe had strong views about this place, didn't he? So I know you love a Daniel Defoe reading because you admire his accent so much. He said, the building yards, the docks, timber yard, the deal yard, the mast yard, the gunyard, the rope walks, and all the other yards and places set apart for the works belonging to the Navy, like a well-ordered city. And though you see the whole place as it were in the utmost hurry, yet you see no confusion. Every man knows his own business. Yeah. Now, the thing is, he was talking about the rope walks, and we are actually in the ropery, which, I mean, you talked about NAM, Roger, this idea of this being the 19th century, in the 18th century, at its peak, this place,
是的，所以汤姆，我们的老朋友丹尼尔·笛福对这个地方有强烈的看法，对吧？所以我知道你很喜欢丹尼尔·笛福的朗读，因为你非常崇拜他的口音。他说：造船厂、船坞、木材场、木板场、桅杆场、枪炮场、制绳厂，以及所有属于海军工程的其他场所以及划定区域，就像一个井然有序的城市。尽管你看到整个地方仿佛处于极度忙碌之中，但你看不到丝毫混乱。每个人都知道自己的业务。是的。现在，问题是，他当时在谈论制绳厂，而我们现在实际上正身处制绳厂，我的意思是，你谈到了楠·罗杰，关于这里是19世纪的想法，在18世纪的鼎盛时期，这个地方，
the ropery, was probably the most futuristic, the most technologically industrially advanced place on the planet. Now, the sublime irony of this is that when we started the podcast, you said there was nothing you hated more than naval rope. And yet you have chosen this place to do this, you know, basically this entire episode, in fact, probably the whole of the podcast has been building to this moment. Yeah. So what is it about?
制绳厂，可能是地球上最具有未来感、技术和工业最先进的地方。现在，这其中最绝妙的讽刺是，当我们开始这个播客时，你说没有什么比海军绳索更让你讨厌的了。然而你却选择在这个地方来做这个，你知道的，基本上这整集节目，事实上可能整个播客都是为了这一刻而铺垫的。是的。所以这是关于什么的？
Tell me about the ropery. I think it's one of the most amazing historic structures in Britain. It's a great monument to the age of Nelson, to the rise of the Royal Navy, to global supremacy. And as you say, it is a glimpse of the future built in the 1780s, 1790s. It is 1,140 feet long. When it's built, it was the longest brick building in. Britain. It is absolutely stupefying. And some of the machinery here, where they still make rope to this day, you can buy it around the corner. It dates back to 1806. So if you want a flavor
跟我讲讲制绳厂吧。我认为这是英国最令人惊叹的历史建筑之一。它是纳尔逊时代、皇家海军崛起、全球霸权的伟大纪念碑。正如你所说，它是1780年代、1790年代建造的对未来的惊鸿一瞥。它长达1140英尺。建造时，它是英国最长的砖砌建筑。
of what it was that powered Chatham, powered this stretch of the Medway, powered the Royal Navy, this is the place to come. So in a way, Tom, this is where the Napoleonic Wars, were won. This is where the Pax Britannica of the 19th century was established. This is what's powering all that, the great dynamo, the ropery,
这简直令人瞠目结舌。这里的一些机械设备至今仍在生产绳索，你还可以在转角处买到。它们可以追溯到1806年。所以如果你想要体验是什么力量支撑了查塔姆、支撑了梅德威河这一段、支撑了皇家海军，这里就是该来的地方。所以从某种程度上说，汤姆，这就是拿破仑战争被赢得的地方。这就是19世纪的不列颠和平（Pax Britannica）确立的地方。这就是为所有这一切提供动力的地方——巨大的发电机、制绳厂、
Chatham Dockyard, the Royal Navy, the infrastructure, the sinews of Britain's greatness. And of course, that continues all the way through to the middle of the 20th century. I think we should fast forward to the Second World War. And we should go out of here, and we should go to an equally exciting
查塔姆造船厂、皇家海军、基础设施、英国伟大的力量之源。当然，这种状态一直持续到20世纪中期。我想我们应该快进到二战时期。我们应该离开这里，去一个同样令人兴奋的
historical site, which is a splendid ship. Let's do that. And we will be ending this podcast by treading the metal boards of a British battleship. So Tom, we've been on an epic journey, haven't we, through Rochester and Chatterman. Now we've reached an earth-shattering conclusion because we have come deep. into the dockyard here at Chatham and we are on a Second World War battleship. So tell me a little about this ship and why you've chosen this and tell me a little bit about a story. Okay.
历史遗迹，那是一艘光彩夺目的军舰。我们去吧。我们将通过踏上英国战列舰的金属甲板来结束这个播客。所以汤姆，我们已经进行了史诗般的旅程，不是吗，穿过了罗切斯特和查塔姆。现在我们达到了一个震撼人心的结论，因为我们深入到了
Well, you know that I love a Second World War battleship. Yeah. And to be more precise, I love a C-class destroyer, which is what this ship, HMS Cavalier, a name that I like to think Charles II would very much be approved of. Yeah, Prince Rupert, Charles I'd all love that. They would all have loved it. That's what this is. A C-class destroyer. What's your favorite kind of destroyer?
查塔姆造船厂的腹地，我们在一艘二战战列舰上。所以跟我讲讲这艘船，以及你为什么选择它，再给我讲一个小故事。好的。
What class do you? Probably B. But a C-class is quite good. I like all destroyers, but I probably rank top three, C, B, probably A, in that order. And also, I think also very nice is the colour. So for those you can't see it, it's a kind of lovely turquoise. And it blends in with the turquoise of the River Medway, which is behind us. Gosh, that's well.
你知道我喜欢二战战列舰。是的。更准确地说，我喜欢C级驱逐舰，也就是这艘船，骑士号（HMS Cavalier），这是一个我想查理二世会非常赞同的名字。是的，鲁珀特王子，查理一世都会喜欢的。他们都会喜欢它。这就是这艘船。一艘C级驱逐舰。你最喜欢哪种驱逐舰？
So, anyway, so. That's a painterly eye. It absolutely is. So this ship is, it was launched in the Second World War. It fought in Norway. It joined a convoy, going to the Soviet Union and back. You say it, surely. She.
你属于哪个阶层？可能是B级。但C级也相当不错。我喜欢所有的驱逐舰，但我可能会把C级排在前三，B级，然后可能是A级，按这个顺序。而且我也觉得它的颜色非常好看。所以对于那些看不到它的人来说，它是一种可爱的绿松石色。它与我们身后梅德威河的绿松石色融为一体。天哪，说得真好。
And then she sailed out to join in the final stages of the War in the Pacific. So absolutely a reminder of Chatham's role in the Second World War. But I think that this ship is also a memorial to the decline of Chatham because this ship got decommissioned in the 1970s and Chatham gets decommissioned in 1984 and really with the closing of the docks so much that had made Chatham Chatham for 400 odd years ends.
所以，不管怎样……真是具有画家般的眼光。绝对是的。所以这艘船，它是在二战中下水的。它在挪威战斗过。它加入了一个前往苏联并返回的护航船队。你说的是它，当然。她。
So in a sense where we are now is a reminder both of Britain's glory days in the Second World War but also of the geopolitical and economic decline that followed and in that sense I think this is a perfect place to conclude the journey the odyssey
然后她起航去参加太平洋战争的最后阶段。所以这绝对是对查塔姆在二战中作用的提醒。但我认为这艘船也是对查塔姆衰落的一个纪念，因为这艘船在20世纪70年代退役了，而查塔姆在1984年退役，随着造船厂的关闭，真正让查塔姆成为查塔姆的400多年历史就此终结了。
that you were talking about so we've gone from Arnage Hillfort Roman Bridge and now we are in the 1980s In a very real sense Tom we've covered all English history the story of
所以从某种意义上说，我们现在所在的地方既是对英国在二战中辉煌日子的提醒，也是对随之而来的地缘政治和经济衰落的提醒。从这个意义上说，我认为这是结束这段旅程的完美地点，也就是你一直在谈论的那场奥德赛。
I'm about say one town but really two towns Rochester and Chatham yeah but joined by a single high street joined by a single high street and let's not end on a downbeat note no because I feel what we've gained from this is a sense of the extraordinarily
所以我们从阿奇斯山丘堡、罗马桥，一直走到了20世纪80年代。从非常真实的意义上说，汤姆，我们涵盖了所有的英国历史，
rich history of Chatham, but also I've learned. What have you learned, Dominic? I've learned that Chatham is not just a town, Tom. It's a community, and I think that's lovely. What about you? Yeah, I can't argue with that. We've been welcomed with such hospitality,
我本来想说一个城镇，但实际上是两个城镇，罗切斯特和查塔姆，是的，但它们由一条单一的高街连接在一起。由一条单一的高街连接在一起，我们不要以低沉的调子结束。不，因为我觉得我们从中收获的是一种查塔姆极其丰富历史的感觉，而且我也学到了东西。你学到了什么，多米尼克？我学到查塔姆不仅仅是一个城镇，汤姆。它是一个社区，我觉得这很美妙。你呢？是的，我无法反驳这一点。我们在街上受到了如此热情的欢迎，
aren't we on the streets? I think we've learned a lot of streets of Chatham. Probably more than the people listen to this podcast have learned from us. I hope that they've learned something, which is go to Rochester High Street, walk down it, Get to Chatham High Street, then come to the docks, and you couldn't be happier. All of English history is there.
不是吗？我想我们对查塔姆的街道有了很多了解。可能比听这个播客的人从我们这里学到的还要多。我希望他们学到了一点，那就是：去罗切斯特高街，沿着它走，到达查塔姆高街，然后来到造船厂，你不会再比这更快乐了。所有的英国历史都在那里。
On that shocking bombshell, we should probably say goodbye to Chatham, goodbye to Rochester, and goodbye to the listeners. Goodbye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
伴随着这个令人震惊的重磅炸弹，我们大概该对查塔姆说再见，对罗切斯特说再见，也对听众们说再见。再见。再见。本集节目尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。